Musik Tiese, Tiese, ein Mensch und eine Maschine, ein Roboter singen gemeinsam ein Lied, ich fand das eine schöne Message, eine schöne Botschaft und auch Roboter sind Teil dieser Gesellschaft. In Zeiten, wo alle Angst haben, dass ihr Job von KIs geklaut wird, haben wir dann so ein Beispiel, wo eine Zusammenarbeit wirklich zu ganz tollen neuen Dingen führt. Und ganz im Ernst, sind Computer und Menschen nicht immer schon Hand in Hand in Richtung Wunder gelaufen? In Richtung Wunderwelten gelaufen? Das ist die erste KI-generierte Podcast-Üvo-Folge, die ihr hier hört, wo natürlich auch ein bisschen politischer Wille dahinter steckt. Das sollte klar sein. Aber ich bin ein großer Fan von Robotern, sie haben leider noch nicht so den Alltag erobert, wie wir das dachten eigentlich.
Viele Filme aus der Vergangenheit zeigen das Jahr 2011, die weite Zukunft. Ja, und schon mit vier, mit Robotern, die durch Läden fahren und Leuten servieren. Und das erinnert mich daran, dass ich neulich in einem Restaurant war, was immer schon bei uns war in der Stadt, nämlich Connies Diner, Shoutout, an dieses amerikanische Diner, was von außen wunderschön aussieht, wie so ein Südstaaten Diner, sieht ganz toll aus, mit so einer riesen Veranda, innen drin dann so klischeehaft natürlich mit den Route 66 Plaketten. Na klar, die Hörner an der Wand. Genau, aber schon sehr cool gemacht. Wirklich so, gibt es dann so Booths mit diesen typischen klassischen Lederbezügen und diesen Tischen, wo man eng beieinandersetzt, aber irgendwie auch sehr bequem, mit sehr vielen Bänken. Und Conny Steiner ist fantastisch, habe ich immer gerne gegessen, früher Kindergeburtstage gefeiert und so, immer mit Freunden abgehangen.
Und turns out, immer wenn die Rocket Beans von der Gamescom nach Hause, zurück nach Hamburg fahren, kommen wir mit dem Bus einmal an, machen sie seit Jahren traditionell bei Conny's Deiner halt in meiner Heimatstadt, 200 Meter, von wo ich geboren bin. Ganz toll, hab ich mich sehr gefreut darüber, das zu erfahren. Ach cool. Und dann habe ich das mal irgendjemandem gesagt, so, wie kann das denn sein, der macht das da, wie cool, und die so, ja, besonders der Servierroboter. Und ich so, es gibt einen Servierroboter in diesem Laden, in dem ich seit Jahren war, und dann aber auch lange nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt, ja ja und inzwischen haben die einfach einen Servierroboter
an den Start gebracht und das war ich neulich zum ersten Mal seit der ganze Zeit mal wieder da und ja erfuhr darum immerzu Another One Bites The Dust, was immer aus ihm blärrt, kündigt ihn so ein bisschen an. Das ist im Robotergesetz vorgeschrieben, dass die sich ankündigen müssen. Man hört das und man hört, irgendwer kriegt gerade, und es ist so schlimm, weil alle Aufmerksamkeit ist auf dir, wenn du deine Bestellung bekommst. Ja. Da ist er wieder. Serviert er wirklich, oder musst du von dem das Essen runternehmen so ein bisschen? Der Roboter hat süße Augen und ein Bildschirm vorne, ist aber prinzipiell, es sieht aus wie ein Dyson, diese Ventilatoren, nur ein bisschen breiter und in der Mitte hast du so ein Regal, so ein fahrendes Regal. Eigentlich ist der Servierroboter, Roboteraspekt ist gering, Serviergross ist ein fahrendes Regal mit Tabletts drin. Und wie ist das denn mit Trinkgeld? Also gibt man dem Roboter Trinkgeld oder ist es dann... Kann man sich das sparen oder wie läuft das denn? Es gibt dieses Problem nämlich, dass der anscheinend sehr fehlanfällig ist. Ich dachte, dass der sehr unrealistische Gehaltsforderungen hat und er droht eine Gewerkschaft zu gründen. Er hat so eine Gewerkschaft vergründet, er führt den Betriebsrat komischerweise an und hat erschreckend gute Argumente. Und streikt. Seitdem es Zetschi-Bitti gibt, ist er so zündende Argumente. Wir müssen ihn entlassen. Wir können ihn nicht entlassen. Das ist Arbeitsschutzgesetz. Er ist ein Roboter. Das ist ein Roboter-Schutzgesetz. Und er streikt. Ansonsten bestreikt er uns. Er bestreikt uns. Man kriegt so rote Augen. Ist wie ein Robot, nur Streik. Oder so schlafende Augen. Wake me up, wenn bessere Gehaltsbedingungen start. Aber es ist so spannend, also stell dir vor iRobot, aber es geht nicht um Tötende Roboter, sondern auf ihr Recht bestehende, auf das Recht bestehende Roboter. Sofort Streiken, so Courtroom-Drama, sofort Mindestlohn. Kriegen diese rote Augen und alle, oh nein, er will uns umbringen. Nein, nein, nein, er hat nur andere Gehaltsvorstellungen und möchte Urlaub machen. Es gibt diesen einen Job, weil er halt so fehleranfänglich ist, von einer Serviererin, die hinter dem Herr läuft und kontrolliert, dass er alles richtig macht. Aber das ist ja wohl der schlimmste Job der ganzen Welt. Das heisst, es kommt düddel-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm-düm Nimmt halt alles weg. Es ist nicht wirklich der Sinn der Sache. Er hat die ganze Zeit seine Mama im Hintergrund. Ja, er kann auch nicht machen, was er will. Es ist nicht wirklich ein Roboter. Es sieht aus wie jemand, der sich fernsteuert. Aber ich will doch, und dann kommt er zum Tisch und dann dreht er sich und dann kann man das auch von ihm. Aber wie du schon sagst, da kamen wir, Roboter sind noch nicht da, wo sie sein könnten. Ja, das ist schwierig. Ich meine, so fangen Maschinen halt oft an. Also hinter dem ersten Bagger mussten auch Leute mit Schaufeln hinterherlaufen. Die gucken, wenn er nicht richtig Bagger hat, dann müssen wir eingreifen. Das ist vielleicht nur der erste Schritt. Vielleicht geht's weiter. Aber kann natürlich auch sein, dass am Ende einfach Menschen als Roboter verkleidet werden, weil es einfach gut ankommt, als Marketing-Gag. Also so sehe ich das jetzt hier. Vielleicht ist das sogar von der reinen Technik her schlecht, aber Marketing-Gag ist gut, so dass irgendwann wir in so eine vielleicht dystopische Zukunft nahen, wo Menschen mit Mindestlohn in Roboterkostüme gesteckt werden, die sich dann irgendwie beleidigen und treten lassen müssen, weil alle denken, es sei ein Roboter, sind es aber gar nicht und die kriegen noch nicht mal Mindestlohn, weil das Robotergesetz nur für Roboter gilt und nicht für Menschen in Roboter. Roboter-Kostüm, Menschen übernehmen Roboter-Jobs. Genau, Menschen müssen Roboter-Jobs übernehmen, weil sie technisch nicht gut funktionieren. Und es wird uns so eine Zukunft vorgegaukelt, in der alles robotisch perfekt funktioniert, aber eigentlich sind es alles Menschen. Das ist auch mal ein Science-Fiction-Drama, an das wir noch nicht denken. Wir starten mit Robby. Robby sind Inder, das war ja immer unsere ... Genau, dass KI, KIs eigentlich nur Inder sind. KIs sind eigentlich Inder, die das einfach nur abarbeiten, weil es billiger ist.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein Drama. Wir starten mit Ronothan. Ronothan hat Geldprobleme.
Ist Roboter?
Nein.
Weil es ein merkwürdiger Name ist.
Nein. Ronothan hat sein ganzes Geld beim Cyber-Bingo verloren, hat wirklich alles auf fünf gesetzt.
Oh nein, der Double Vortex ging an den User Cybercypher. Verdammt. Oh, verdammt, ich, Robothin, habe meine ganzen Credits verloren. Verdammt, ich, Robothin, das ist wieder ein Aspektebeitrag über diesen Film. Da kommen so Szenen, die werden so eingespielt. Oh nein, ich, Robothin, habe alles versaut. Alles ist jetzt im Intranetet. Verdammt nochmal, es ist so schwer, einen Job zu kriegen, weil alles nur von den Robotern gemacht wird. Ich als Robothon, der Geldprobleme hat, ich kann überhaupt keinen Job mehr kriegen. Und dann kommt so ein verhüllter Typ mit so einer Kapuze. Ein Witter-Kapuzen-Mensch erscheint in meinem Wohnzimmer. Hey, ich bin Cyberdan. Nein, Dan, hi. Hast du gerade gesagt, dass du einen Job brauchst? Ja, pscht, pscht, pscht, alle, pscht, pscht, pscht, man. Hey, pass mal auf, die Cyberpolizei sind hinter uns her. Die Fliegen in Mikrofone, die kleinen Mücken, die kleine Mikrofone sind. Hey, weißt du was, icharte kurz, warte kurz. Ich habe mit der Cyberfliegenklatsche den Cyberdrohne-Mini-Mikrofon. Jetzt sind wir unter uns, Jonathan. Endlich sind wir unter uns. Ich verrate dir ein Geheimnis. Ein gut gefühltes Geheimnis ist ein Cybergeheimnis. Und zwar, Roboter gibt es gar nicht. Es sind alles Menschen in Kostümen. Und ich kann dir dafür sorgen, dass du auch ein Kostümroboter wirst, okay? Okay. Okay. Aber wie? Komm mit, Mann. Leute werden mich erkennen. Komm, wir gehen mal in ein Cyber-Apartment. Oh nein, wo wohnst du denn? Wo ist dein Cyber-Apartment? In Cyber-Uptown. Ah, Cyber-Up-Town? Ja, Mann. Was, ein gefährliches Pflaster. Geht, aber nicht so gefährlich wie Cyber-Downtown. Das stimmt wohl. Komm, wir fahren lieber, wir nehmen lieber die Bahn. Die normale Bahn, die deutsche Bahn. Die gibt es immer noch. Die deutsche Bahn. Die gibt es noch, den ICE nehmen wir. Und dann wird er verkleidet als Roboter und arbeitet als Roboter. Ja, habe ich mir schon gedacht. Und dann werden die Leute, sind super unhöflich zu ihm und er merkt eigentlich erst mal durch die Augen der Maschine, wie der Mensch wirklich ist, weil er sozusagen lernt, dass Menschen super grausam sind. So ist alle grachen von der dachte so ist der mensch sind eigentlich Roboter in Menschenkostümen die eigentlich so schlimm sind und die menschen war eigentlich die ganze zeit ziemlich cool die aussage des Films ist nicht klar super unklar die aussage des Films man kommt aus dem Kino und denkt ich weiß nicht ich bin wogegen ich bin jetzt gegen was ja ich bin dagegen ich bin gepolt und dann wie Magnet ich weiß noch nicht wo ist wo weiß noch nicht gegen was genau. Und die Freunde, mit denen du rausgehst, sagen, ich bin auch dagegen. Ja, dagegen, krass. Ja, wir haben die gleiche Botschaft mitgenommen. Und dann unterhält man sich abends dann, wogegen man ist und alle sind gegen was anderes, weil die Botschaft war nicht klar. Aber ist das nicht ein toller Film, der auch polarisiert, der das Spektrum der Polarisierung auch mal so ein bisschen aufmacht? Und du kannst quasi gegen alles sein? Das hat sehr langsam am Anfang nicht gebraucht, wo er sehr oft gesagt hat, ich Ronathan. Das hat nicht so lange ge... Der Zuschauer muss wissen, dass die Figur Ronathan heißt. Mit wem hat er gesprochen? Er hat mit niemandem gesprochen. So spricht man in der Zukunft. Er sagt das zu sich. Er sagt es zu sich. Samantha, meine Schwester, wir müssen unbedingt einen Job bekommen in Cybertown. Aber das ist wirklich so letztens... Stimmt, das war beie aber ich lese gerade höre herr der ringe die gefährten und die letzten vor den augengrösser ohren ich bin ich werde so geflamed dafür augen augen dass ich das höre und es ist einfach das gleiche naja und dann habe ich und das letzte die also flott den fummel an seinem kabel rum das wird schon funktionieren ohne dass sie die aufnahmen abbrechen müssen oder hörst du mich noch klangst auch gerade so ein bisschen für mich als wärst du nur eine rabotter in fleischanzug stefan deine augen werden ganz rot der mindestlohn muss neu verhandelt werden? Jawohl, ich werde nicht ... Ich möchte 60 Prozent unserer Einnahmen von Patreon.com.
Okay.
Ich möchte jetzt 60 Prozent. Schliesslich kümmere ich mich um das ganze Backend, das ganze Finanzoffice und Cyber, die Cybertransfers.
Moment mal, Stefan Tietze war die ganze Zeit ein Roboter? Wo ist der echte Stefan Tietze, ist die Frage.
Jetzt, ich spiel den Roboter. Du spielst einen Roboter, der Stefan Tietze spielt, okay, um zu sehen, wie Menschen reagieren, wenn sie, okay, du, du, du, Robothen. Robothen, Robothen, Robothen, es ist ein Musical, Robothen, es ist ein Musical, es ist die Cybertown, wir sind Untergrund, wir können machen, was wir wollen. Unter uns. Ich bin der Ronathan, ich liebe den Top, doch ich habe ihn verloren an den Robo-Cop. Ja, das ist Robo-Town in Robo-Town, das ist Robo-Town, das ist Robo-Town, das ist Robo-Town, Ich bin Ronathan in Robo Town, ja das ist Robo Town, ja das ist Robo Town, ja das ist Robo Town, ja das ist Robo. Ich bin Ronathan in Robo Town, ich hab den Job verloren an den Robo-Kopf.
Ich bin Samantha, Robithans Schwester, bin kein Roboter, oder vielleicht doch?
Oh, Plot Whistle, Plot Whistle, Plot Whistle, Plot Whistle, Plot Whistle, Plot with a learn, plot with a learn, das wird ein Plot with a musical, wir haben großen Spaß und das ist der erste Song, ihr seid gut drauf, wir sind Jonathan in Uptown.
Es ist eine Vierzig-Minütige-Dialog.
Die singen erst so viel, dass man denkt, wann sprechen sie wieder, dann kommt so eine lange Dialogszene, man denkt, wann singen sie wieder, am Ende kommen alle raus und sagen, ich liebe Musicals, ich hasse Musicals, Polarisierung, Polarisierung, Polarisierung, Polarisierung, Polarisierung, Oui. Ich habe noch nicht in der Warteschleife gehangen und es kommt ja immer der Satz, sind Sie mit allen verstanden, dass dieses Gespräch zu Schulungsdeckzwecken aufgenommen wird. Bei jedem, in jeder Scheiss-Wadeschleife kommt dieser Satz. Ja. Wie viel Milliarden Terabyte an Daten, wie viel kann man lernen, wie viel kann man lernen? Wie lange müsst ihr das noch immer aufnehmen? Ja. Will man aktuelle Beispiele nehmen? Hat mal irgendwer von euch da draußen einen Job gehabt, wo man die dann vorgespielt bekommt? Was für Schulungszwecke? Wer hört sich das alles an? Sitzen dann da Lehrer, Lehrerinnen, die Leute ausbilden, die in so Callcenters arbeiten? Die hören sich diese ganzen Milliarden Terabyte an Gesprächen an? Theorie, es gibt überhaupt keine Lehrzwecke. Eben, diese Gespräche werden auch nicht aufgezeichnet. Das ist einfach nur ein Trick, damit die Leute freundlicher sind. Weil wenn du weisst, ah, das wird aufgezeichnet zu Lehrzwecken, ah, das kann sein, dass die Person, mit der ich telefoniere, dafür zur Rechnung gezogen wird oder irgendwie eine Strafe kriegt, weil das alles aufgezeichnet ist, ist man freundlicher. Es könnte sein, dass das alles komplett nur fake ist, weil man herausgefunden hat, vielleicht haben die tatsächlich mal so ein Lehrding gemacht und meinten, wir brauchen irgendwie so Beispielanrufe für Leute, die neu anfangen. Lass uns das aufzeichnen. Und die haben gemerkt, die Leute sind viel freundlicher. Alle haben mega gutes Feedback gegeben und gesagt, die Leute sind viel freundlicher, seit wir denen sagen, dürfen wir für Schulungszwecke das mitschneiden, weil plötzlich wird der andere als Mensch wahrgenommen, als, ah, stimmt, der hat eine Ausbildung bekommen. Leute werden geschult, Leute haben hier eine Ausbildung als Kallzer mit dabei. Ich bin jetzt plötzlich das Lehrbuch, ich bin sozusagen der Standardkunde, der stellvertretend steht für Menschen, ja, und ich glaube, das hat einen positiven Einfluss darauf, wie freundlich man ist. Vielleicht gibt es das alles gar nicht. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dann wäre die Frage, warum ist diese Lüge erlaubt, aber ja, vielleicht ist es einfach. Warum sind Lügen erlaubt, ist unsere Welt im Eimer. Die Wahrheit fehlt, die Lügen regieren die Welt. Ich frage mich aber, weil du hast ja auch beim Callcenter gearbeitet, hast du da jemals Aufnahmen gehört? Nein, ich wurde eingeschult, mir wurde alles beigebracht und dann hat mein Vorgesetzter gesagt, so, jetzt warten wir bis Leute anrufen und die ersten drei Anrufe wirst du falsch machen. Gott ey, ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin immer einer dieser drei ersten Anrufe. Und mein erster Gedanke war, die armen Leute, die jetzt anrufen, die jetzt an mich geraten, mein erster Anruf war, weißt du, sie hat eine Zahnversicherung für, ähm, also wo hatten sie eine Zahnversicherung? Nein, ich rufe an, weil mein Fernseher nicht funktioniert. Okay, aber haben Sie mal einen Teletext probiert? Ich leite sie kurz weiter und dann so, es passiert nichts, nur knack. Was soll ich machen?
Ich kann sie immer noch hören.
Was soll ich panisch, was soll ich jetzt machen, rufen hören?
Auf eine ganz simple Anfrage.
Was darf ich machen?
Wie, was darf ich machen?
Darf ich ihn abwürgen?
Ich lege einfach auf.
Wieso, ich lege einfach auf?
Ich muss jetzt...
Das ist wirklich mir mal passiert.
Da wurde ich aufgelegt. Habe ich ständig gemacht. Callcenter. Wenn du nicht weißt, was du machen sollst, leg auf. Naja. Das ist die zweite Regel, die du gelernt bekommst. Da wusste ich, ich habe ein Problem, was man nicht so einfach lösen kann, als ich zweimal das jemandem gesagt habe und bei beiden Mal habe ich mich weggedrückt. Da habe ich gesagt, vielleicht ist das ein Problem, was nicht so, oder was nervig ist, überheben zumindest. Naja,, ich habe mich wirklich gefragt, wo landen diese ganzen Daten? Ich dachte eher, vielleicht ist es nicht aus, also vielleicht stimmt das, dass sie es aufzeichnen, aber es ist nicht aus Schulungszwecken, sondern aus rechtlichen Dingen, Gründen. Ah nee, wir haben das auch band, wie sie Ja sagen zu unserem Vertrag. Ah ja. Dass man sich nicht rauswieseln kann, nicht rausfrebeln kann. Ich habe das gar nicht gesagt. Ich habe leicht gehüstelt, was manchmal wie ein Ja klingt, aber ich habe gar nicht Ja gesagt. Ihr Mitarbeiter hat mir versprochen, dass ich weniger zahlen muss ab nächstem Monat. Aber wir hören kurz rein, dass zu Schulungszwecken wie praktisch, dass wir zu Schulungszwecken alles aufnehmen, zu Schulungszwecken, play. Das he heißt, du kannst dich dann aber auch dagegen entscheiden, dass das aufgezeichnet wird und dann kannst du machen, was du willst. Dann bist du Wild West, dann kannst du Immunität. Dann hast du juristische Immunität. Dann kannst du tun und lassen, was du willst. Rufmord, du kannst am Telefon Rufmord begehen, Verleumdung, Erniedrigung. Was rät man, was raten normale Menschen einem, dass man ein Ja drückt oder dass man sagt, nein? Ich drücke immer ja. Ich drücke auch immer ja. Ich denke mir, ja, ich bin, ich bin freundlich. Ich denke mir nämlich auch, das Gegenüber ist wahrscheinlich auch professioneller, wenn ich es aufnehmen lasse. Kann sein, ne? Ja, ja. Die, für die ist ja auch Rechtsfreie Zone. Ist das die wahre Lektion des Menschen? Er ist nur wirklich gut, wenn er aufgezeichnet wird, wenn er zur Verantwortung gezogen wird. Ja, wir sind doch auch, wir reden nur miteinander, wenn wir aufzeichnen. Das stimmt. Und wir sind wirklich hier ehrlich und gute Mitmenschen miteinander. The Call. Ruf mich an, damit ich ehrlich bin. Ruf mich an, damit ich ich sein kann. Oh, das ist vielleicht die Szene, irgendwann Samantha und Robothan. Robothan. Seit wann ist er Robothan? Weil er ein Roboter ist. Ah, okay. Er ist ja Robothon geworden. Hast du den Plot überhaupt nicht mitbekommen? Nein, doch, mitbekommen und nicht verstanden. Und Samantha sagt irgendwann, Robothon, ich weiß, dass du ein Roboter bist, aber ich liebe dich trotzdem. Und Robothon sagt, stopp, schweig. Schweigweib. Schweig. Was ist das für ein weirder Schweigweib?
Ich weiss, dass Menschen lügen können, aber sie lügen nicht am Telefon.
Menschen lügen nicht am Telefon.
Und dann sagt er, ruf mich an, sag's mir am Telefon. Ruf mich an, sag's mir am Telefon, und Samantha holt ihr Cyberhandy raus. Was eigentlich nicht ganz normales Handy ist, mit ein bisschen Neongrün dran. Da hat die Regulierung ein bisschen Neongrün dran. Wir haben keine Cybertechnologie. Wir haben keine Zukunftstechnologie. Und die Verfolgungsjagd ist rein Stock-Footage. Ist rein Stock. Wir haben auf Shutterstock, äh, verfolgt, Chase haben wir gegoogelt. Car Chase. Und haben das erste genommen, was es ist. Und wir haben so einen Neon-Pass-Filter drüber. Und wir haben so einen Neon-Pass-Filter drüber. Und wir haben so einen Neon-Pass-Filter drüber. Gar nicht in die Zeit, die wir erzählen wollen. Das Auto ändert sich auch. Das ist ein so altes 60er-Jahr. Auf manchen ist kein Verfolgungsjagd. Nur ein
roter Ferrari. Wir jagen es ja Hunde
hinterher, weil wir einfach alles genommen haben,
was wir gefunden haben. Wir hatten kein Geld.
Unabhängig davon. Unabhängig davon.
Samantha ruft ihn an am Telefon und gesteht
ihre Liebe nochmal am Telefon und sagt
Robberthon, ich liebe dich.
Und man denkt, hat es auch mit der Budgetkürzung
zu tun, dass das Gespräch, was
plötzlich noch was in einem Raum war, plötzlich am Telefon weitergeführt wird, mit einem harten Schnitt in der Mitte, was so klingt wie, dann fiel die in groß der Plotthole auf und sie mussten das Gespräch nachdrehen, aber die beiden hatten nicht zur gleichen Zeit Zeit. Ja, und dann mussten sie unabhängig voneinander aufnehmen, obwohl es ein Musical ist, obwohl es eine Live-Performance ist.
Und dann sagt ihr Ring, ring, ring die Liebe, ring, ring, ring die Liebe, ich ruf dich heute an, dass wir zusammenfahren in die grosse weite Welt, in die grosse weite Welt. Und Robertin sagt, ich bin ein Mensch, ich bin ein Mensch, ich war die ganze Zeit schon ein Mensch. Moment, Robinson ist wieder Ronathon? Ich bin ein Mensch, bin ein Mensch, hab den Roboter nur gespielt, die ganze Zeit war War ich ein Mensch, ich liebe, fühle, schmecke. Und wenn du was anderes denkst, bist du nur eine lahme, lahme Schnecke. Ende. Ende, Akt eins. das wird ein Klassiker, das wird ein absoluter Broadway-Klassiker. Robertan schränkt sich Ronathan, finde ich richtig gut. Ich kann nicht sagen, wo und wann und was, aber ich habe neulich ein Musical gesehen, ein Amateur-Musical. Oh, okay, aber du darfst nicht sagen, was und wann. Kannst du Uhrzeit, kannst du die Uhrzeit des Tages, das nicht mal.
Nein, ich möchte nur sagen.
Ich will das Datum nicht wissen, ich will nur wissen, um welche Uhrzeit hat es angefangen.
Ja, wann fangen abends Musicals an?
Ja, da sag's mir, sag's mir.
Okay, 19.30 Uhr oder 20 Uhr, weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Warum musst du darum Geheimnis machen?
Ich mache darum nicht Geheimnis, ich weiß es ehrlich nicht mehr, ob es um 19.30 Uhr, 20 Uhr anfing, weil es war 19.30 Uhr erst Einlass.
Ich würde sagen 20 Uhr, aber nage mich nicht darauf fest.
Das war ein Musical, das war ein Amateur-Musical. Und vieles hat nicht funktioniert. Die Story war weird, Hanebüchen und so, egal. Und der letzte Song war dann, also es wurden nicht viele Konflikte, die Konflikte wurden nicht so wirklich gelöst. Und dann kam schon der letzte Song. Jetzt hast du mich leiser gemacht beim Sprechen. Sorry. Machst du mich leiser. Bist du auch hier drauf? Wir müssen kurz technische Probleme kennen. Ja, ich hab's leider so ein bisschen roboterisch bei dir drauf. Ja, okay, vielleicht fällt jetzt endlich auf, dass ich tatsächlich einfach ein Roboter bin. Müssen wir abbrechen, Florentin, oder kommst du klar? Jedenfalls kamen wir dann zum letzten Song und dramaturgisch habe ich gedacht, das kann er jetzt nicht zu Ende bringen, der Komponist oder Texter, weil wir haben noch ganz viele Probleme, die offen sind, das kann doch unmöglich schon der Finalsong sein, war der Finalsong. Und dann war es sehr lustig, weil erst haben alle gesungen, ja basically, seid einfach gut drauf, habt eine gute Zeit, tanzen, tanzen Party, das macht euch zu glücklichen Menschen wieder. Und man denkt, okay, verstehe ich schon irgendwie, anscheinend ist das der Weg in ein glückliches Leben, tanzt doch einfach eure Sorgen weg. Dann habe ich gemerkt, die Idee des letzten Songs war es eine Strophe und dann der Refrain. Und diese Strophe hat dann diese Figur, die gerade nach vorne kommt, löst ihr Problem und dann ist der Refrain, wie dann alle sagen, tanzen, tanzen, tanzen, party, party, party. Dann, das hat mit der ersten Figur noch gut geklappt, der zweiten Hauptfigur noch gut geklappt, und dann kam so eine Nebenfigur auf die Bühne, wo man sagt, ah, die hat ja auch noch dieses ungelöste Problem. Okay, hat es auch noch geschafft, in der Strophe das zu lösen. Dann kam die Antagonistin auf die Bühne, wo noch nichts klar war. Der Streit war immer noch offen, es hat dramaturgisch nicht aufgegangen, diese ganze Story, und ich wusste, ah, er hat jetzt acht Zeilen um dieses merkwürdige Knäuel, was mal ein roter Faden hätte sein sollen, irgendwie zu Ende zu bringen und zu entzerren. Viel Spaß. Ich sehe den Refrain kommen. Du hast acht Zeilen, ich weiß gleich, was der Refrain ist. Der Refrain wird sein, tanzen, tanzen, tanzen, Party, Party, Party. Die Sängerin denkt auch, Leute, jetzt aber schnell. Du warst doch gerade noch in dieser Müllpresse. Und dann, wie löst du das jetzt in dieser einen Strophe, ging nicht, ging nicht auf, es war hilarious, ich hab mich kaputt gelacht, ich hab mich während des Songs schon drüber gebeugt zum Kumpel, hab gesagt, wie löst da diesen Konflikt jetzt in dieser einen Strophe, aber hat nicht geklappt, aber es ist so lustig, Musicals, das ist einfach sehr viel Arbeit, glaube ich, viel entheddern auch, Eine Story zu Ende zu bringen, in diesem, klar hat man im Film auch gewisse Hindernisse, Hürden, Grenzen, in denen man arbeiten muss, aber du hast in Musicals ja auch einfach Musik und du hast den Referent, der sich wiederholt.
Und es ist auch leichter, Konflikte aufzubauen, als sie zu lösen, also zu sagen, die beiden hassen sich, weil XY, weil früher und der Vater hat den umgebracht und so, aber wie löst man das mit, naja, oder? Am Ende. Schwamm drüber, Schwamm drüber, Pletsch, Pletsch, Platsch, wir nehmen den Schwamm, Pletsch, Pletsch, Platsch, wir nehmen den Schwamm, Pletsch, Platsch, Schwamm, Schw! Endakt zwei. Und Musical-Enden funktionieren auch nur, wenn danach tosender Applaus ist, weil die haben immer dieses Rumm-Ende, jede Musical-Nummer hat ein Rumm-Applaus-Ende. Die sind so awkward, wenn man den Song entweder akustisch nicht verstanden hat oder generell die Story nicht verstanden hat, man den Konflikt nicht verstanden hat. Das sind sehr selbstbewusste Enden. Die sind darauf geschrieben, dass der Song cool war, nachvollziehbar, lustig, raw, standing ovations danach kommen. Aber so ein selbstbewusstes Wammende ist total merkwürdig danach schwamm drüber okay anscheinend ist das eine lösung für alles drüber okay aber weil der hat ja die ganze familie versklavt von einem anderen und jetzt einfach schwamm drüber oder der song und die lösung war jetzt schwamm drüber oder was okay und die die musical darsteller harren Verbeugen sich verbeugen sich. Warten auf Blumen, die ihnen zugeworfen werden. Nichts kommt leider. Vielen Dank für die Blumen. Du hast ja Der Ringe gehört, oder was? Ja, Der Ringe gehört. Der Ringe gehört. Ist da ein Musical drin eigentlich mal? Nein, aber da muss ich so drüber lachen, weil da verlässt Frodo, am Ende erzählt er, redet er mit sich selbst, damit J.R.R. Tolkien in direkter Rede diese Story beenden kann. Und es ist wirklich, dann redet Frodo die ganze Zeit laut, er ist ganz alleine, aber er sagt Dinge. Und dann sagt J.R.R. Tolkien, J.K.R. Tolkien sagt dann tatsächlich einfach, sprach Frodo laut mit sich selbst.
Und es ist so lustig, weil es ist viel geiler, wenn er das so sah, weil es viel mit Emotionen mit sich bringt. Ja, ja, nicht Frodo dachte, was das für eine tolle Reise war. Wie uncool jetzt dieses epische Werk, und dann sind sie auf Ammon-Heyn und die grosse Schlacht und Brumme fiel im Kampf. Er starb ehrenvoll, bla bla bla bla bla bla, Riesensteaks, Fantasy-Epos und am Ende sagte Flodo, ich fahre jetzt lieber alleine los, dachte er, ich verstehe schon, warum das nicht so geil ist, aber die Lösung ist, sprach er zu sich, so lustig, mit seiner kleinen Hobbit-Höhle, mit seiner kleinen Stimmchen, mit seiner Stimmchen, sagt er zu sich selbst. Sagt er, so wir müssen jetzt los. Versprach er sich. Das ist grossartig, das ist schwierig, grossartig. Aber ich höre es gerne. Aber du bist jetzt am Ende angekommen, oder? Nee, ich bleibe mal komplett alles durch. Genau, Gefährten ist durch, ich habe jetzt angefangen mit Die zwei Türme. Ah, okay, interessant. Es ist ein bisschen anders im Buch, diese Stelle, wo du immer drüber stolperst, mit dem Prank. Ah ja, mit den Nazgul-Pranks. Mit dem Nazgul, die diesen Prank fahren. Prancing Pony. Pranking Pony. Das ist ein bisschen was anderes im Buch. Ja, da ist eher ein Furzkisten dann involviert oder was. Ja genau, da hast du diesen Eimer bei der Decke mit Wasser. Also da, wo sie im Film mit den Schwertern in die Betten strechen und alle denken, jetzt sind sie tot, so schnell, ich hab doch noch zwei Stunden auf der Uhr, nein, sie haben nur geprägt. Das passiert auch, aber die Nazgul weiss nicht unbedingt, dass die im Ort sind und wenn ja, es ist ein grosser Ort, die wissen nicht, wo sie sind. Das heißt, sie stechen willkürlich in Betten rein oder was? Ähm, nein, nein, nein, sie sind schon da, wo sie glauben, dass die Hobbits untergebracht sind, aber Aragorn hat sie, Streicher hat sie woanders hingebracht und die suchen schon noch die ganze Nacht nach denen, aber sie haben nicht in Kissen gestochen und gesagt, ja, dann good job, good job, gut gemacht, gut gemacht, danke Bernd, danke Bernd, besonders gut reingestochen, dann würde ich sagen, treffe uns in zwei Wochen und bis dahin macht's gut. Reist du noch nach Norden? Ja, genau. Dann lass uns aber ein Stück zusammen noch. Nach Taxi teilen. Ja, nee, genau, das ist nicht so. Haben die Nasrkuhl den Dialog in dem Buch? Nein. Gar nicht, ne? Ach und zu doch ein bisschen. Ja, wirklich? Ja, der Hexenmeister von Angmar redet natürlich ein bisschen was. Und was sagt er so? Weiss ich nicht mehr. Ist schon lange her. Schon 18 Stunden her. 18 Stunden, ist ja fast die Herr der Ringe Trilogie, ist das ganze Zeit her. 27 Stunden und so dauert das erste Buch zu hören. Es ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr cool. Ich liebe das, es ist so selbstbewusst, es ist so selbstbewusst geschrieben. Ich habe noch nie ein selbstbewusstes Buch gehört. Aber es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, wie feststehend er über diese Welt spricht, als wäre sie da. Diese Pseudohistorie ist so genial. Im Gegensatz zu anderen Autoren, die so, ich glaube es war Gondor, wo vor 400, 500, lass mich nicht, nagel mich jetzt nicht fest, vor 430, also irgendwas, das überlege ich mir dann noch. Nee, aber stellt euch so eine Stadt vor wie, ja, sagen wir mal, wie New York, aber es ist nicht New York, sondern Gotham. Aber prinzipiell wie New York. Aber halt im Mittelalter. Genau. Das ist schon noch. Das ist wahr. Ja, das stimmt, das ist der normale Stil von Fantasy-Autoren. Aber Tolkien ist da wirklich so ein bisschen fester im Sattel, das stimmt schon. Der hat das alles durchdacht. Diese Details sind halt insane, die machen es halt gut. Die aber auch den Leser nicht so unbedingt interessieren. Die auch keine Rolle spielen. Es ist so ein bisschen, ja, ach so funktioniert das Kanalisationssystem von Minas Tirith. Hast du dir gut überlegt? Ich kenne das ja als Rollenspieler, Pen and Paper, wenn man sich da Sachen überlegt in der Welt, gerade wenn man selber eine Welt baut, dann hat man, denkt man so eine geniale Idee irgendwie und dann muss man die ständig irgendwie einbauen, ohne dass die Spieler interessiert, ohne dass die es einen Grund gibt, das jetzt zu machen, aber man will es trotzdem irgendwie einbauen. Und dann natürlich völlig zu Recht ein Fan-Favorite, Tom Bombadil, der gar keine Rolle spielt mehr und ich jede Entscheidung verstehe, den rauszuschneiden aus dem Film. Absolut, hundertprozentig. Es gibt immer wieder von der Ringe Fans, schade, dass Tom Bombadil hat. Nein, es ist so, die Figur ergibt null Sinn, ist so seltsam, eine mächtige Figur, die kurz den ring hat kein ein Einfluss hat der Ring auf ihn, er wird nicht unsichtbar, lässt ihn kurz verschwinden, macht dann einen Scherz und zeigt den Frodo wieder, singt die ganze Zeit, ist so ein rundlicher Lebemann, der die ganze Zeit dichtet und singt und wahnsinnig mächtig ist. Und hält eigentlich nur die Story auf. Weil ich glaube, der holt vor allem dann, ich habe, Hobbit oder Herr der Ringe, holt der die mehrmals einfach aus Gefahren raus, die Hobbits.
Ja, einmal dann noch. Da irgendwie dann bei den Geisterhügeln oder was, oder dann ist der im Baum verschlungen und ständig kommt Tom Bomber, den holt die raus. Genau, zweimal redet den. Was soll das denn? Also, ich meine, warum hilft er denen dann später nicht mehr? Exakt. Ja, du bist im Baum eingespornt, okay, aber du bist irgendwo im Turm gefangen, in Mordor.
Beides war ja bei ihm in der Nähe, in seinen Ländergrenzen, die er sich abgestellte. Keine Ahnung, es ist ein super mächtiger Charakter, der dann aber auch, und das macht ihn dann so cool im Rat von Elrond, wo besprochen wird, was machen wir mit dem Ring. Ach, da ist er auch dabei. Nee, nee, nee, aber er ist Thema. Warum geben wir den Ring nicht Tom Bombardier? Und dann ist die Lösung, weil er ist so mächtig, er ist derlteste die elben nennen ihn irgendwie der faser vaterlose weil er von anfang an dabei war ist der älteste älteste wesen was in mittelerde lebt wir könnten es ihm einfach geben und die sagen ja wahrscheinlich würde er den verlegen weil er hat kein interesse an diesem ring er würde ihn vergessen und verlegen und dann ist er wiederum sehr gefähr. Und dann könnte er nicht gegen Sauron besiegen und dann
wäre schon so, ja, er wäre,
dann werden auch alle tot dann aber,
weil er würde da auch zur Runde
gehen, wenn ganz Sauron seine Streitmächte
auf Tombobody lenkt. Ah, okay, verstehe.
Dann würde er sterben. Zwar zuletzt,
aber er würde sterben und wir alle auch.
Und es war irgendwie dann wiederum
ein bisschen befriedigend, wie der das abholt.
Aber diese Rolle macht keinen Sinn. Und kriegt auch kein gutes Ende, ne? Also irgendwie alle gehen dann die grauen Anfurten und so und schönes Ende und ewig hin. Nicht spoilern! Sorry. Aber Tom Bombardier ist einfach immer noch da in seinem Ding. Man muss schon auch viel schneiden. Also ich glaube, Er der Ringe, das ist schon sehr gut, dass da viel geschnitten wurde. Hat Percy Jackson gut gemacht, hat da gute Entscheidungen getroffen. Ja, aber ich höre das, macht sehr viel Spaß. Du bist auch schuld, weil du mich wieder auf Herr der Ringe gebracht hast. Ich habe wieder Bock bekommen. Ah, okay. Wegen deiner Rands. Ja, ja. Wegen deiner Ständig. Es war aber kein Sinn, die er hat, die sie direkt hinbringen können. Das war eigentlich Arrogon von Anfang an, als der Schwertkönig gedacht, weil eigentlich im Buch hat er immer sein Schwert dabei, um allen eigentlich zu zeigen und deswegen hätte er eigentlich gar nicht so... Ja, dein furchtbarer Pedantismus hat mich... Pedanterie. Ich finde, so ein Fantasy-Universum muss auch in sich schlüssig sein und stimmig sein. Und deswegen darf man das durchaus auch kritisieren, wenn da ein paar Dinge nicht ganz so gut funktionieren. Ich find's vielleicht okay. Biegt euch das zu Recht.. Biegt wie ihr wollt, macht euch die Welt aus Lehm.
Sandkastenprinzip, Sandkastenprinzip, das ist das Sandkastenprinzip.
Und im dritten Akt geht es nur noch um das Sandkastenprinzip.
Macht dir die Welt, wie sie dir gefällt, hier hast du eine Schaufel, hier hast du einen Eimer.
Nichts reinigt sich auf fucking Eimer. Weimar. Die Videorepublik in Weimar. Ja. Schleimer. Schleimer finde ich auch gut. Es fällt mir immer erst nach, während dem Applaus aus. Immer während dem Applaus fällt mir das erst ein, was alles gute Reims gewesen wären. Davor ist es zu spät. Ja, völlig richtig. Das wäre immer geil. Improvisierte Musicals, das machen wir mal irgendwann. Irgendwann laden wir mal hundert Leute ein, hundert unschuldige arme Menschen, vor denen improvisieren wir ein komplettes Musical. Wir haben keine Instrumente, wir haben nur Klatschen. Wir haben keine Skills und keine Instrumente. Von daher viel Spaß damit. Grosse Patschehände nur, wo wir den Rhythmus klatschen. Spielst du Lotto? Ich spiele kein Lotto, nein. Ich bin kein Glücksmensch. Ich wollte einmal Lotto spielen, weil ich hatte ja diesen Tag, den ich schon oft erwähnt habe, wo mir sehr viele glückliche Dinge passiert sind. Unglaubliches Glück und tatsächlich rückblickend war das auch so, dass sich mein gesamtes Lebensglück, also das klassische spielerische Glück, sagen wir mal, auf diesen einen Tag konzentriert hat. Vielleicht hätte ich an dem Tag Lotto spielen können, dann hätte ich ganz viel Geld verdienen können, um es dann anzulegen in Kleingeld und dann wäre das ganze Geld wahrscheinlich verschwunden irgendwann in einem grossen Erdloch. Willst du Lotto spielen? Hast du Geld? Ja, ich hätte schon gern sehr viel Geld. Ja, ich auch. Ich glaube, ich wäre sehr gut darin, mit sehr viel Geld gute Entscheidungen zu treffen, für mich, um für mich im Sinne von Lebensqualität zu steigern. Ja, okay, das macht dich, glaube ich, zu einem ehrwürdigen Sieger. Nö, ich meine nur, sehr viele sehr reiche Menschen, man denkt, wofür gibt ihrer Geld aus, das macht ja keinen Sinn. Ich glaube, das könnte ich gut. So dass die armen Menschen, die Neider sagen, ach ja, guck mal, der gibt seinen enormen Reichtum sinnvoll aus, für sich. Er ist ein wahnsinnig unsympathischer. Nach seiner persönlichen egoistischen Perspektive. Aber nach seiner Perspektive gibt er das Geld gut aus. Ich hätte schon gern Geld, aber ich habe dann neulich irgendwie, da wurde dann so Bilanz gezogen im letzten Jahr und es gab irgendwie in Deutschland 167 oder irgendeine Zahl, irgendeine erschreckend hohe Zahl zwischen 100 und 30. Ich dachte mir, wow, jetzt hat er echt immer die Zahlen, jetzt hat er immer die Fakten, die Leute lernen was hier und dann sagt er, ja oder halt irgendeine andere Zahl.
Oder eine andere Zahl.
Ich gebe euch mal eine Beispielzahl, damit ihr mal seht, wie eine Zahl aussehen kann. Ja, so in der Größe ungefähr. Aber es ist jetzt nicht die Zahl, aber irgendwas, es ist auch nie in der Nähe, aber einfach mal eine Zahl, weil ich muss euch ja eine Zahl geben, sagen wir mal 178. Oh es waren 187. Nah dran. 187 Menschen haben im letzten Jahr eine Million oder mehr im Lotto gewonnen. Okay. Ich finde das sehr viel. Wow. Es sind sehr viele Menschen. Was war der höchste Gewinn? Weiß ich nicht. Was ist der niedrigste Gewinn? Also genau eine Million? 187 Menschen Menschen, finde ich viel mehr als gedacht. Es spielen offensichtlich sehr viele Menschen Lotto, dass das passiert. 107, sagt sie, wenn in einem Jahr Millionäre durch Lotto. Ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, krass ist es … Und dann wurde aber gegenübergestellt, der Gewinn von Lotto, dem Unternehmen, mehrere hundert Milliarden Gewinne wurden eingestrichen durch Lotto. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich verstehe bei Firmen, verstehe ich oft, wohin das Geld geht. In Forschung und Entwicklung, andere Produkte an den Start zu bringen, grösser werden, Expansionen oder so. Bei Lotto verstehe ich es nicht. Da habe ich mir Mitarbeiter vorgestellt, die seit Jahren das gleiche Gehalt bekommen, in so einem Hochhaus irgendwo in Osnabrück sitzen. Ich habe mich gefragt, und die kriegen ja mit, wie viel diese Firma einstreicht, die nicht wächst, die immer die gleiche Anzahl Mitarbeiter hat, die muss ja nichts in ihr eigenes Wachstum packen. Weißt du, Roto ist ja fertig, fertig. Ist fertig,
das Produkt ist da. Das Produkt ist da,
kaum Arbeit, kaum Arbeit,
Drucker, drucken,
wir drucken das, aber beim Chef, wir haben wieder ein Problem,
Drucker, ja, tauscht den
Treiber, wechselt den Treiber, ja,
das ist fertig, wir haben wieder kein Problem.
Wir haben uns jetzt überlegt,
ob wir nicht auch koffeinfreien
Kaffee
anbieten wollen. Okay, wir müssen den Hohen Rat einberufen. Okay. Und dann kommen die zusammen. Und das sind dann so die Themen, die die besprechen. Weil mein Problem ist, wenn wir mit der gleichen Kaffeemaschine koffeinfreien Kaffee machen, dann wurde davor in der Maschine ja Koffein-Kaffee gemacht. Ah, die Koffein-Reste. Da sind noch Reste drin und dann habe ich teilweise auch Koffein im koffeinfreien Kaffee. Aber ja, bei der Arbeit, Bernd, fällt es dir da auf? Mir fällt es nicht, also es, ja, da bin ich ehrlich, mir fällt es nicht hundertprozentig auf. Es ist einfach nur etwas, was ich weiss und wo ich mir denke, weil, ne, Herr Lotto, wir alle wissen, wie viel Umsatz letztes, Lothar, Lotto, wie viel es letztes Jahr war. Und deswegen überlegen wir uns, wäre es nicht möglich, zwei Kaffeemaschinen in die Kaffeeküche zu stellen. Eine für Koffein-Kaffee und eine für koffeinfreien Kaffee. Das würde jetzt vielleicht 80 Euro kosten oder so von den 168 Milliarden Euro Umsatz, die wir letztes Jahr gemacht haben. Erstmal vielen Dank, dass du dieses sehr wichtige Thema hier zu uns bringst, weil das nicht mitzuspassen. Und ich finde, deswegen habe ich das grosse Meeting einberufen, um da ausführlich drüber zu sprechen. Von daher, lass uns das jetzt ausgiebig diskutieren. Also ich bin ja erstmal offen für andere Vorschläge. Ja, ich habe damit kein Problem. Also da geht es ja wirklich um marginale Reste und ich will ja auch von deinen Resten nichts haben, ich habe ja weniger Koffein in meinem Kaffee. Aber Erika, guck mal, du bist doch Vegetarierin, du willst doch auch nicht, dass mit demselben Messer, mit dem jetzt jemand seine Leberwurst schmiert, dann du irgendwie deinen Tofu da schneidest. Das macht ein anderes Problem auch, weil die Spüle könnt ihr einfach anmachen, wenn die voll ist, mach die Spüle doch einfach an. Aber das ist jetzt mal ein ganz anderes Thema, Erika, das ist doch ein ganz anderes Thema, es ist ja einfach nur eine Rücksichtnahme. Es geht ja gar nicht unbedingt jetzt darum, dass tatsächlich praktische Rücksichtnahme sind, sondern einfach eine gewisse Rücksichtnahme und auch eine gewisse Respektsituation vor den anderen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern, die eine andere Präferenz haben, was Kaffee angeht. Und sie kauften keine weitere Maschine und einigten sich darauf, die Maschine häufiger zu reinigen. Und ich denke mir so, das ist doch Lotto, die haben keine Probleme, das sind die Stakes, über die gesprochen wird. Wobei, ich glaube, ein grosser Teil des Geldes bei Lotto fließt einfach in die innere Verteidigung. Weil wenn ich bei Lotto arbeite, mach den Save noch dicker, pack noch einen Zentimeter oben drauf. Weil ich würde ja versuchen, an die Gewinnerlose zu kommen. Ergibt das Sinn? Ich würde versuchen, die Maschine zu manipulieren. Was ist Lotto noch mal? Mit den Kugeln? Ich würde versuchen, an die Maschine ranzukommen. Nach Feierabend gehe ich in die Maschinenhalle und versuche da irgendwie die Zahlen von den Kugeln da irgendwie umzuändern oder so. Das würde ich probieren.
Oder muss dann das Gewinnspielamt sagen, ihr fahrt so viele Milliardengewinne ein, erhöht die Millionäre.
Nee.
Es ist schon eine perfekte Idee. Warum kommt, ich verstehe nicht, oder ist das, ich habe mal gehört, es ist auch staatlich, teilstaatlich. Verstehe ich auch nicht genau. Kommt da viel dann zurück an den Staat? Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Diese Vorstellung, dass es so ein trockenes, leeres, weisses Bürogebäude ist, das Lotto-Unternehmen. Wie heißt das denn nochmal Das ist Aktion Mensch. Das ist was anderes. Das ist ein anderes Glücksspiel mit dem Aktion Mensch los. Weil das kann ja auch sein, dass das irgendwie wohltätigen Zwecken zukommt. Wir haben keine Ahnung. Wir wollen das auch weder gutheißen noch schlechtheißen. Wir haben einfach überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ah, Lotto gehört staatlichen Unternehmen. Sie sind zudem im deutschen Lotto- und Tottoblock organisiert, um nicht der deutsche Tottolotto-Block. Früher Ostblock, heute deutsche Lotto-Tottoblock. Um die staatlichen Glückwünsche wurde wunderbar. Okay, sie sind nach staatlichen Grundsätzen organisiert. Ich finde es so interessant, es ist unglaublich, dass dann niemand auf die Barrikaden geht, wie der Lotto, die da arbeiten, durchdrehen, weil das Unternehmen Milliardengewinne aufbaut und trotzdem werden die Fenster nicht so aufgebrüht. Ist es nicht in den meisten Firmen so, dass die wahnsinnig viel Gewinn einstreichen und trotzdem die Mitarbeiter nicht so viel kriegen? Ich finde es nur nachvollziehbarer, dass das Geld auch woanders hinfließen kann. Die können sagen, ja, wir brauchen ganz viel für die grosse Maschine. Ja, verstehst du, was ich meine? Die Maschine dreht Kugeln im Kreis. Wie viel kann die, also ich meine, wie viel kann die pro Monat kosten? Ich finde es bei Lotto halt so wahnsinnig konkret. Es ist so klar, wofür man Geld braucht und die Gewinne sind insane. Und wenn man bei Amazon arbeitet und man wird sehr schleiße bezahlt, so, Also, die ist kacke und furchtbar und sollte nicht sein, aber ich verstehe, dass die sehr viel reinvestieren könnten, dass sie wachsen wollen, dass sie noch ein Logistikunternehmen dranhängen, dass sie eine Bank gründen, was auch immer, Streaming-Service. Also ich verstehe, dass die expandieren und da sehr viel reinfällt, aber ich finde es noch, ich finde es eins schwieriger nachzuvollziehen.
Ja, stimmt schon. Es ist sehr übersichtlich. Warum bin ich nicht Millionär? Warum sind nicht erstmal die Mitarbeiter bei uns Millionär? Ja, das sollte man sich erstmal die richtige Frage. Ich habe nur mich eine Zeit lang mit diesem McDonald's-Monopoly-Skandal beschäftigt, wo jemand die Gewinnerlose geklaut hat und dann über die Mafia versucht hat, an das Geld zu kommen und so. Und das dauert ja erstmal eine ganze Weile, bis sowas auffliegt. Also, ich frag mich auch, wenn jetzt die 178 neuen Millionäre, wenn die alle Rubensbichler heißen, mit Nachnamen, gibt's irgendjemanden, der sagt, Freunde, was ist hier los? Es ist mal jemand aufgeflogen. Oder alle aus einem Ort oder alle, die in der gleichen Schulklasse waren.
Das ist dann so ein Detective-Conan-Ding, so die haben alle nur acht Buchstaben im Namen oder irgendwie so ein Ding. Es gibt so einen Fall von einem Menschen, der gewonnen hat, eine extreme Summe gewonnen hat, abgeholt hat und sowas. Und dann gab es nochmal einen Gewinner und nochmal einen Gewinner
in den verschiedenen US-Bundesstaaten
von dem gleichen
Gewinnspiel. Und irgendwer
hat dann mal überlegt,
okay, das ist jetzt häufiger gebrochen worden
der Jackpot irgendwie als sonst, aber
erstmal nichts wahnsinnig Ungewöhnliches.
Dann wurde aber
recherchiert über den zweiten Gewinner
und der hing mit dem ersten zusammen. Und dann wurde recherchiert, die letzten fünf Gewinne hingen auch schon irgendwie, entweder familiär mit ihm zusammen oder dann wurde der Name recherchiert, den gibt es gar nicht und so. Und dann kam raus, dass er ein Mitarbeiter des Unternehmens war. Der hat sich die Lose geschnappt. Die hat sich die Lose geschnappt, ja. Geil.
Wahnsinnig genial.
Warum ist darüber keine Filme? Weil meine Mutter hatte mal früher einen Ferienjob, die hat lange, ihr erster Job, war in einer Losefabrik. Geil. Also Kirmeslose und so. Ja, ja. Ich meine, da gewinnst du halt den grossen Bären. Ja gut, das sind dann auch so ... Ja gut, irgendwo fängt man ja klein an, vielleicht so eine TKKK-Kindergruppe. Deswegen ist unser ganzes Haus voller riesen Teddybären gewesen und den grossen Gewinn. Es kann ja sein, dass jede Lotterie immer so abläuft und es immer nur Betrug ist und es einfach niemand weiß und man nur deswegen nicht gewinnt, weil irgendjemand anders ständig die Gewinne einstreicht und nicht, weil man Pech hat. Vielleicht hat man gar kein Pech, aber es gibt überhaupt keine Gewinnerlose mehr im Topf, weil die schon abgezwackt wurden von jemandem. Kennt irgendwer einen Lottogewinner da draußen von euch? Müsste es ja geben. Es gibt jedes Jahr 187 Millionäre von Lotto. Das wird gesehen, müsste doch einer da vom Podcast-Ufer hören. Es gab mal bei uns in der Schulzeit so einen riesigen Lotto-Jackpot, wo alle drüber geredet haben, oh, der ist super krass angewachsen. Und da stand sogar in der Lokalzeitung, wurde mein Mathelehrer interviewt, über die Wahrscheinlichkeit, da zu gewinnen. Und ich fand das so süss, dass diese Lokalzeitschrift gesagt hat, okay, Mathe-Experten, Wahrscheinlichkeit, Herr Riedelsbruch vom Gymnasium. Weil er steht eins in Mathe gerade.
Genau, ja.
Mündlich. Und dann meinte der so, ja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist eins zu drei, whatever, Millionen oder irgendwie sowas. Aber ich wünsche allen, die mitspielen, viel Spaß. Und es war so süss lokal irgendwie so. Da wird einfach der Mathelehrer der Schule gefragt und der denkt sich, ja das ist halt, das kann ich von der Webseite lesen, wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist. Da müsst ihr nicht unbedingt einen Mathelehrer fragen, aber gerne stelle ich meine Expertise zur Verfügung. Es ist wie ein lokalen Tankwart, über die Benzinpreise aufzufangen oder so die lokale Apothekerin über die Morphium-Krise. Ja genau, Europäatkrise. Gab es das hier auch? Nein, in Reutlingen gab es das nicht. Aber es ist einfach so süss, dass sie dann auch Reden und Antworten stehen und nicht sagen, ich habe da überhaupt keine Ahnung, ich habe damit nichts zu tun, ich stehe am ... Also ich könnte es ausrechnen, aber warum? Also warum fragen Sie mich? Und auch das ist absolut trivial. Allein die Tatsache, dass Sie das nicht können, zeigt, dass Mathelehrer versagen eigentlich, weil eigentlich sollte das jeder können. Aber na gut, ich mache es euch. Du machst es dir schnell. Ich rechne es dir schnell aus, kein Problem. Und dann wird die Mathe-Maschine angeworfen. Da wird die große Mathe, der große Abba-Kuss, die grosse Kugel-Ding. Es ist ähnlich wie so diese, in so Wartezimmern gibt es immer diese Draht-Achterbahnen mit den Klötzen. Die existieren aber auch ausschliesslich in Wartezimmern. Also das ist nur so Wartezimmer.de. Ich meine, wenn du ein Wartezimmer einrichtest, dann brauchst du so ein Ding. Das ist genau so wahrscheinlich eine Firma, die Milliarden Umsatz einstreicht, weil die genau weiß, immer wenn irgendwo eine neue Arztpraxis oder irgendwie Friseur, wo die Kinder irgendwie währenddessen was machen müssen, wird diese Drahtachterbahn verkauft. Hast du damit gerne gespielt? Ich habe nie verstanden, was der Spass daran ist. Ich glaube nicht.
Weil das Loch ist zu klein, was der Spaß daran ist.
Ich glaube nicht. Weil das Loch ist zu klein,
als dass es diese Idee hat,
dass man es ohne, dass es den
Draht berührt.
Das ist nicht die Doktor-Bimmer-Idee.
Es ist nicht diese
Draht, sondern
da sind ja mehrere Klötze dran mit einem Loch
drin, die du entweder gemeinsam oder einzeln
und das vielleicht auch so, erst einzeln die Klötze, dann gucken, ah, kann ich zwei schieben, ja, kann ich drei. Andererseits, warum muss ich Zeit sparen bei diesem Spiel? Aber du hast wahrscheinlich fünf verschiedene Bahnen. Ja, okay. Oder vier. Das ist schon die Deluxe-Variante. Nee, nee, du hast gelb, ich glaube, gelb, grün, blau, rot. Ja, okay, mag sein, gelb, grün, rot. Eine ging sehr steil hoch, dann wieder runter.
Da kannst du es dann runterfallen lassen.
Das ist schon ganz geil.
Ich meine, grün.
Okay, Kreise ist auch geil, weil du kannst dann gucken, kann ich mit einer Bewegung den Klotz oder ich will so ein Ding eigentlich.
Aber mal frage, ich will so ein Ding.
Wur sind die dafür konstruiert sogar?
Sind das sogar Wartezimmer-Spielzeug?
Du meinst, das waren früher mal Waffen, die nicht gut angekommen sind und deswegen jetzt eingesetzt werden?
Goki Motorikschleife.
Die Motorikschleife.
Ich finde die so geil einfach.
Vielleicht ist das für kleine Kinder das Beste, was es gibt.
Und die denken, Alter, können wir bitte zum Arzt gehen?
Bitte, bitte noch mal zum Arzt.
Ich will diese Motorikschleife haben.
Ja, genau.
Also jeder erinnert, es sind drei. Du hast mal wieder völlig recht gehabt, deine Erinnerung drückt dich nicht, meine schon. Weil ich habe mir ein grünes ausgedacht, was es nicht gibt. Ist das eine Art Mandela-Effekt? Das kann sein, sehr viele Leute fragen, es gab eine grüne weitere Bahn der Motorikschleife. Also sie sehen so aus, Flutti, um ein Gedächtnis zu refreshen. Die sind schon geil. Und es gab die gelbe Bahn, die relativ boring einfach nur ein Bogen ist, dann gab es die blaue Bahn, die ich genial fand. Die blaue Bahn war richtig cool, die ging hoch und dann so horizontal über den Boden schwebend, sehr Achterbahn-mäßig. Es ist schon die Idee einer Achterbahn. Man fährt das
ganz hoch und dann lässt man es runterfallen
und dann ist es so ein bisschen noch weiter
und dann muss man den Rest schieben. Aber was macht man dann?
Ich glaube, die Kleinkinder, für die es ist, die Motore
gelernen sollen, können damit nichts anfangen,
weil die noch nicht diese
Achterbahn-Assoziation haben und gar keinen Spaß
daran haben. Und ich glaube, die älteren Kinder, die
dann wieder Bock haben, weil es so ein bisschen an Achterbahn erinnert,
die denken, was ist das Spiel?
Falls kleine Kinder gerade zuhören, schreibt uns mal, was die Faszination daran ist. Also vielleicht ist es ja wirklich mega spaßig, wir checken es ja nicht. Ich bin Hendrik, ich bin drei Jahre alt und ich wollte mich bezüglich eurer Motorik-Schleifen-Frage aus Folge melden. Erstmal vielen Dank für diese illustre Geschichte und eure Erinnerungen an die damalige Zeit bei euch. Bei mir ist es ja noch sehr aktuell und ich muss sagen, dass ich schon sehr viel Spaß habe, Dinge von A nach B zu bewegen. Nicht nur, dass man diese kleinen Miniziele erreicht, sondern es ist auch spannend für mich, die verschiedenen bunten Formen zu ertasten, um damit herumzuexperimentieren, nicht alle Formen klappen zum Greifen, gleich, gut, und es ist nicht unbedingt einfach für mich, weil ich noch sehr klein bin und die Motorik sicherlich hier und da noch ein paar Schwächen aufweist, Dinge von A nach B zu bringen. So muss ich häufiger mal das Ding, das ganzehen, auf 180-Grad-Drehungen machen oder ich lasse es gar fallen. Ich erinnere mich an, letztens, da war ich mit meiner Mutter in der Praxis und da fiel mir das ganze Gerät aus der Hand und ein schillerndes Klappern erfüllte den ganzen Raum. Ich schrie, ich schrie, ich schrie am Spieß. Die Blicke suchten und fanden mich letztlich und ja, letzten Endes habe ich es dann aber auf den Tisch gestellt und konnte die Reise vollenden und mein blaues Klötzchen bis ans Ende der Schleife fahren.
Aber um auf eure Frage zurückzukommen, was es für einen Sinn zweckerfüllt, so sei euch gesagt, dass wenn man da sitzt beim Kinderarzt und ich weiss nicht, ob eure Erinnerungen da noch sehr präsent sind, man hat Angst vor der Spritze, vor dem grossen Spritze, die wirklich dämonengross vor dir erscheint und der Arzt, der dich versuch abzulenken, aber daran scheitert, jagte die Spritze in dein Popöchen und davor hat man grosse Angst und etwas im Wartezimmer zu haben, was lustig klappert und bunt ist und farbenfroh und formenfroh. Der, so soll ich gesagt, das hilft. Wisst ihr, die Kindheit habe ich vor allem als eine Epoche der Kontrolllosigkeit erlebt und dieses Gestell gibt mir einfach eine gewisse Kontrolle zurück. Ich kann selbst entscheiden, welchen der Klötze ich bewege und wohin, so wie ich selbst teilweise bewegt werde. Meine Mutter zerrt mich in das Auto, fährt mich irgendwo hin, ich kann nicht kontrollieren, wohin ich fahre. So kann ich die Klötzchen bewegen und bekomme dadurch etwas Kontrolle über den Alltag zurück. Eine schrittweise Rückgewinnung meiner Kontrolle, meines Kontrollverlustes. In diesem Sinne wünsche ich euch alles Gute, vielen Dank für euren Podcast. Henrik Vier aus Reda-Wiedenbrück. Ja, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das Spaß war. Kann mir auch vorstellen. Ich will so ein Ding. Viel cooler fand ich diese Kreisel, die man oben einsetzt und dann klacken sie dagegen gegen das eine Ende. Was? Und dann rollen sie weiter und klappen gegen das andere Ende diese Kreisellaufbahn, wo so Stäbe drin sind mit verschiedenen Formen drin. Die fand ich richtig geil. Fand ich richtig geil. Das war richtig cool. Jetzt alles nicht mehr. Heute daddeln sie alle nur an ihrem iPad. Sind los Stefan.
Heute liegen in der Warenzimmer wahrscheinlich iPads mit diesem Spiel. Ja, mit der
Motorik-App. Ja, kannst die Motorik-App
anmachen und kannst die Formen.
Wir fassen ja gar nicht mehr an, die Kinder.
Mach den Mund wieder zu.
Es ist wieder
mundoffig da gegenüber.
Pöbelmund. Ey, was die Kinder, die Pöbel. Und so blieben die Pöbelmünde offen. Man sagt ja über Leute, die sich aufregen, Mundatmer. Nein. Doch, habe ich letztens gehört. Über Leute, die sich aufregen? Da war wieder so ein Haufen Mundatmer unterwegs. Mein Vater hat immer Fliegenfänger gesagt. Ah, okay. Nahhaft. Ich atme lieber durch den Mund. Wirklich? Ja, ich liege manchmal im Bett und denke mir, jetzt den Stress durch die Nase atmen will ich mir gerade nicht geben. Ich mache die Klappe auf und ab geht's. Du bist viel direkter, du lässt alles sofort rein. Ja, aber die Nase ist immer halb verstopft, ist viel zu eng, ich brauche grosse Mengen Luft.
Ich liebe das, ich liebe das, dass die Nase filtert, die Nase hat einen Spam-Filter für Scheiße. Ja, aber ich befeuchte deinen Mund, alles bleibt schön feucht und benetzt. Ja, aber manchmal denke ich mir, muss ich mich wirklich dazu bringen, nicht den Mund aufzumachen und irgendwann denke ich mir dann, wenn ich schon eine halbe Stunde im Bett lag, dann denke ich mir, wisst ihr was, jetzt einfach alle Klappen auf und los geht's. Let's go! Und dann wird der Mund aufgesturbt. Es ist auch nicht so ein langes, wo so eine Klappe runterfährt, sondern einfach so offen und los geht's. Dann wird geschnarcht wahrscheinlich auch. Das kann sein, ja, das kann sein, dass dann geschnarcht wird. eine Bekanntheit mit Aufnahme, die nimmt
nachts auf die die Geräusche, die sie von sich gibt, gibt es da so Apps dafür. Und turns out, die hat die furchtbarsten Schnarchgeräusche der Welt, schluss sie von sich. Es ist mehr ein Schreien als ein Schnarchen. Es ist wirklich so ein ... So was, es ist halt so ein Auf und Ab in der tonalen Bewegung drin, es ist insanely laut, es ist furchtbar, es sind die Schmerzen und was dann? Ja, ja, du hast es rausgefunden, dass du in der Nacht um dein Leben schreist, ist es dann auch so, wenn man dann, und was dann? Ja, ist es dann, wenn man so die Nacht mit jemandem verbringt und dann schläft man so nebeneinander ein und dann sagt man, Karsten, schläfst du schon? Ja. Karsten, ich wollte dir nur sagen, dass ich sehr laut schnarche und im Schlaf schreie. Okay. Okay, wollte ich nur sagen. Okay, weißt du das? Ich habe mit einer App, ich nehme alles auf, was nachts passiert. Gut. Okay. Nicht, weil ich akzeptiere keine vor mir in deinem Leben. Okay. Also wenn du gesagt hättest, es ist eine andere Frau, hätte das gehört, dann wäre Feierabend gewesen. Nee, nee, nee. Nee, okay, kein Feierabend. Also ich hatte schon, also ich hatte schon, was? Also es ist, glaube ich, nein, aber Kassel ist, lass uns morgen,ass es morgen. Okay, okay. Gut Nacht, Schatz. Gut Nacht. Okay, gut. Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Pssst, hey, hey. Der Zugegleist! Der Zugegleist! Hey, hey. Was? Hey, du schnarchst nicht, das ist einfach ein Schreien. Ja, ich weiss. Das ist einfach ein furchtbares Schreien. Das habe ich dir ja gesagt. Aber wann macht man das Licht an? Bei so nächtlichen Diskussionen? dass nachts, nachts gelten andere Regeln. Ja. Ich sag dann immer gern, nachts kämpft jeder für sich allein.
Weil wenn nachts Partner, Partnerin, das sag ich so gerne, weil wenn nachts Partner, Partnerin schnarcht und man ist wach und man weckt den Partner vielleicht oder der Partnerin, weckt man damit, um zu sagen, schnarch's. Oder was kann der dann machen, die Person dann machen? Anders hinlegen zum Beispiel, hilft oft, anders hinlegen. Aber es ist so, es ist eigentlich so fast ein Übertritt der Gesetze und Grenzen. Ja, eigentlich schon, ja. Nachts hat man die Klappe zu halten. Ja. Und wenn man, selbst wenn man merkt, dass beide, nachts beide wach sind, wird ja nicht häufig geredet. Nee, nee. Man liegt nachts still. Es gibt dann so einen Punkt, ja. Und ich finde es ein bisschen awkward nebeneinander, weil es gibt keinen anderen Zeitpunkt im Tag, wo man, obwohl beide völlig bei Bewusstsein sind und wach sind offensichtlich, sich einfach nur dem Anliegen und nichts sagen. Du meintest ja immer, dein Traum ist es dann einfach, in normaler Raumlautstärke einfach Gespräche anzureden. Du, die Ulrike hat jetzt aber auch den Parkplatz komplett vollgestellt mit ihren Töpfen. Und es ist nur, weil die Uhrzeit und Dunkelheit es nicht erlaubt, macht man das nicht. Aber in jedem anderen Zeitpunkt des Tages, wo man merkt, wir sind gerade nebeneinander und wach, kann man sagen, dann ist mir der Chef wieder auf die Eier gegangen, weil dann muss ich jetzt wieder den Drucker, irgendwie wechsel, jetzt gleich mein Job, es geht gar nicht zu meinem Aufgabenbereich.
Das ist voller Lautstärke
nachzusagen, das ist alle aufschrecken.
Nachts gelten andere Gesetze.
Absolut, absolut. Es ist einfach das Gesetz der Nacht
und man ist einfach in seinem eigenen
Kopf. Manchmal
freue ich mich auch im Bett noch über Sachen
nachzudenken, dann denke ich mir so, oh da denke ich
jetzt heute, da denke ich noch drüber nach.
Da gehe ich noch mal rein, da gehe ich noch mal rein.
Worüber denkst du da nach? Richtig noch, gehe ich noch mal richtig rein.
Was ist das dann? Manchmal ist es
Vielen Dank. nachzudenken. Dann denke ich mir so, da denke ich noch drüber nach. Da gehe ich noch mal rein. Da gehe ich noch mal rein. Worüber denkst du da nach? Richtig noch, gehe ich noch mal richtig rein. Was ist das dann? Manchmal ist es, keine Ahnung, Urlaub oder so, wo ich noch mal reingehe oder irgendwie ein Erlebnis, wo ich sage, da jetzt noch mal rein oder irgendwie dann noch mal, denke ich mir, manchmal so alte, ich war immer so aus so Skifahren und manchmal fahre ich so im Kopf noch so eine komplette Piste runter. Kannst du dich erinnern? Kann ich mich noch erinnern? Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht herzgetreu, wahrscheinlich skippe ich Teile, an die ich mich nicht erinnere und mein Gehirn fügt es dann zusammen. Aber trotzdem mache ich das nochmal gerne und sage, jetzt stelle ich mich gedanklich nochmal auf mein Snowboard. Das finde ich eine richtig tolle Eigenschaft. Nochmal so kleine Gedächtnis, mentale Gedankenreisen und bei denen wünsche ich euch
auch ganz viel Spaß, wenn ihr diese macht, wenn ihr vielleicht
nochmal... Legt euch mal abends und freut euch mal auf Gedanken von euch.
Legt euch mal hin und denkt einfach diese
komplette Folge nochmal nach. Was war da alles,
was ist passiert und
dann könnt ihr uns ja schreiben,
falls ihr da neue Dinge
gelernt habt. In diesem Sinne,
freut euch auf eure Gedanken, freut euch auf Abend. Macht's gut, macht's gut, schlaft gut, tschaui, tschüss, wir heben ab.